oh is the doctor gonna confront ferry
out note wait it's aliens
[Applause]
[Music]
Big Finish review time and yeah you know
I joke but I I I don't it doesn't bother
me that much but this does fit into the
oh wait it's aliens trope that like I
mentioned more than a few times up to
this point so this particular time and
again as is always the case the the Big
Finish audio story that I reviewed was
selected by my patreon supporters I'll
plug it again at the end but in any case
this I I actually in hindsight I did not
mean to put this one on the list of
options because I just did a sixth dr.
Evelyn Smythe audio adventure and so I
like I mistakenly put this one when I
meant to put I think it was a fifth
doctor when I'd meant to put and I put
this one on the pole instead and this
one ended up wedding so this is two
months in a row with the six doctor and
evil inscribed but the thing is that's
no bad thing because the six doctor and
evil and Smythe are awesome they're like
truly one of the one of the great doctor
campaign compares to right up there with
seven and eight or ten and Donna it's
just fantastic so we also get another
little bonus here which I didn't realize
even though like his face is on the
front but like they it's they kind of
put the like the color filter so I
didn't quite recognize him uh the
brigadiers in this one uh as soon as I
heard the word Brigadier I'm like oh no
wait is it that I heard his voice I'm
like yes I do love the Brigadier and and
it really was a shame that we didn't get
him back on the show he had an
appearance on Sarah Jane Adventures
which was quite nice and sweet but and
and and he actually did get some really
nice acknowledgments and send-offs after
the actor passed away but we do get to
have him here interacting with the Sixth
Doctor for I think
the only time but he doesn't miss a beat
I mean I love the Brigadier in general
but I love especially about this time is
like he's an old pro with this by now
like he's not the doctor shows up says
hi to him and he's just oh yes and the
darks like wait you know me cuz the
Brigadier hasn't met this the same
carnation of the doctor before and he
goes well the clothes you just kind of
show up out of nowhere yeah
yeah I'm pretty sure I know who you are
and yeah uh uh it's it's really great so
plot okay so we have the doctor and evil
and smite they show up at this spot
that's supposedly like a Celtic burial
sites not just sort of a site of some
ancient Celtic stuff then there's a
there's an excavation going on a little
bit of an archeological survey but
there's also some weirdness and like
maybe goblins and fairies except oh wait
it's aliens cause it's Doctor Who of
course it's aliens and so that's your
basic setup and premise and this is one
where the story is actually not great
the more that I think about it this is
probably one of the most predictable
audios that I've listened to so far or
at least main range ones like I've done
I've done say some of the some of the
box sets were like maybe one of the
stories which are only like an hour was
kind of predictable but like the main
range ones the the two the two and a
half hour main range stories usually
have some good twists going on or go in
some directions that I wouldn't have
called in advance but the story is
really pretty predictable here there's
really only one like slight twist that
I'll admit I didn't see coming but only
because I thought the story was already
done with that kind of twist cuz it had
done it earlier where the character that
I called it on and then it did something
different with somebody else that I'm
like oh
okay okay I didn't call it that time but
that wasn't like a major plot revelation
that was just like a complication
so as far as the setup that we get at
the front end how things move forward
what characters behave in what ways for
the most part and then certainly how how
it wraps up towards the end I called
pretty much all of it all the way
through now normally this would be a
real big issue for me because I've
mentioned this a few times before I'm a
story person first and foremost
primarily in all ways i strong narrative
is what I come to entertainment for and
it takes a lot for me to get enjoyment
out of something that doesn't have a
particularly strong narrative
fortunately three really well performed
characters who I love and who interact
phenomenally together and have great
chemistry yeah that'll about do the
trick that brings it like if this had
been with a different companion or the
brigadiere hadn't been there or just
there had been the dynamic of these
three of the six doctor and evylyn smite
and the Brigadier like this this might
have been like really down towards the
bottom for me as it is it's upper-middle
just because they're all so good and
they're their interactions and their
interplay and like the more I hear of
evil and the more I just adore her she
is she's really great and she's so
wonderful and charming and snarky in
that just polite British way it's oh
it's so perfectly written and
masterfully performed but as far as like
substance goes this is this is one of
the more disappointingly straightforward
main range stories I've I've come across
what I've realized as I've experienced
more and more and more Big Finish is I
like Big Finish stories best when they
really lean into the medium and they do
things that would be either very
difficult to do in the TV show format or
you just flat-out couldn't do for
whatever reason be it because
the concepts that you're dealing with
are so abstract that you can you can get
them across for the purposes of the
story but if you actually tried to
visualize it it would fall apart
something like Holy Terror I think falls
into that category oh really well or
just also possibly chimes of midnight so
these sorts of things but even if it's
not that even if it's just I want to not
feel like oh that could have just been
an episode of the show I want it to feel
a little I wanted to feel like Doctor
Who but I want it to feel a little bit
different ambitious in a slightly
different way from what the show does
and the best of Big Finish does that and
this story it just it just kind of
doesn't it just kind of like I'm
struggling to to come up with much more
to say because the story didn't engage
me enough that it's worth me getting
into a spoiler talk again the story's
not bad it's not like I isn't trust me
if it was bad I'd be ranting I'd be
saying and then they do this and this
and it's so stupid cuz I mean unless
you're new around these parts that's I I
do that but it's not stupid it's fine
but the the overall thing itself is made
better than fine thanks to these
characters and it really has been
amazing to me like very first time I
heard the Sixth Doctor in audio is like
okay this is significantly better than
he was in the TV show but like I've
really come to appreciate Colin Baker's
The Sixth Doctor through these audios
particularly when he is paired with evil
and this is now the third time I've
heard the two of them together and it
really does the the downsides of this is
it makes watching him in episodes of the
show all the more painful because it's
just not working and I know it can cuz
it does here but I feel like I feel like
I need to wrap up because I feel like
I'm just kind of circling the same
points
now so this was probably gonna end up
being a little bit shorter than most the
specter of Lanyon more it's it is worth
checking out because the characters are
great the performances are great in the
dynamic and the chemistry is awesome the
story is serviceable it gets the job
done it is a vehicle to give you the
good stuff which is the character
interaction so I'm gonna wrap it up
there the specter of Lanyon more have
you heard it what do you think about it
what is a Doctor Who story audio or
video that youth that you think story
wise was just kind of okay but gets
notably elevated by performances or
interactions for me for like for a
comparison on the show I think robot I
sure would like the story is like what
but I love the banter the banter in that
episode is some of the best so what's
the Doctor Who story that's like that
for you whatever it is drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
whole bunch of stuff to do buttons links
patreon I told you I plug in a second
time link is down below plus links to
other stuff like my book that I wrote
and social media stuff and whatever give
it a look or don't if you don't want to
that is totally ok exatly end of the day
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]